- [Kelly Clarkson] Did
you celebrate 23 years?
- [Tim McGraw] 23 years in
October, this past October.
(audience applauds)
- What's your date?
- October 6th.
- Oh we are October 20th, yep.
I was like I totally know it.
- It's the guy is supposed
to get that wrong.
- No, no, no, my husband and I
have both forgot two anniversaries.
- Oh wow.
- He was hunting and I was like asleep,
and they emailed us and they
were like, "happy anniversary!"
And we were like, "oh my God!"
He was, like, ordering flowers,
and I was, like, calling
him, "oh, ha ha, love you."
I was like, we totally forget, it's fine.
But what did you do to celebrate?
That's huge.
- Gosh, I was in Australia
I think, this was the first
anniversary that we were apart.
- Oh no.
- Yeah, but we were backstage
and I recorded the very first
song that we ever did together.
We did the Spontaneous
Combustion Tour, where we met,
when she was opening for me
on my very first headlining tour,
and we used to do the Tony Rich song,
"Nobody Knows But Me".
- ♪ Nobody knows it but me ♪
I love that one, yeah.
- So I recorded that backstage
with the guys, and we
sent it to her for our anniversary.
- Oh yeah, that's cute.
Okay.
- So that
was my anniversary gift.
- That was pretty cute.
So I just saw two of your
kids backstage, but your two
oldest kids are out of the house.
Are y'all excited about
being empty nesters?
- I don't know if we are
excited about it, we miss them,
Gracie and Maggie-
- You are such good parents.
- And we miss them.
- I'm gonna be like, bye!
I love 'em but bye!